In order to speak well,
you have to speak a lot.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here,
and today I want to talk about
talking your way to fluency.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So we often, you know, hear people say
that they can talk their way to fluency.
People have the impression that speaking
the language is the key to becoming
fluent in the language, the key to
learning the language, we have to use it.
In Japan, they have these, you know,
groups, English conversation groups
where people gather around and speak in
English and, and so I think the idea that
you're gonna speak your way to progress
in the language is, is quite popular.
And I'm not saying that that's,
you know, counterproductive.
But I would like to suggest some
ways to make it more effective.
So I think there are two possible
scenarios, or two polls here.
One is that you're in a place
where the language is spoken.
You're surrounded by the language.
You have lots of opportunity to use the
language, and I think in that situation,
speaking your way to fluency can work.
Remember, in order to speak
well, you have to speak a lot.
So the only question is when are
you able to, or when should you
speak more and more and more in
order to get better at speaking?
So, uh, when I was in Japan,
wherever I had an opportunity, I
was in the country, I used whatever
little bit of Japanese that I had.
Although I maintained my input activities.
So if you're surrounded by friends, you're
in the country, you've met people, maybe
you have a common interest, you're playing
tennis or you're into some other activity.
So you're with people that you know,
uh, it's a comfortable environment.
It becomes increasingly
a familiar environment.
Uh, you have common interests, so
actually your input, excuse me, your
output, your speaking is triggering
input for you because you are able
to participate initially just a
little bit, eventually more and more.
And when you talk about
something, something more or
less familiar to you comes back.
I always found, even when I'm
quite good in a language, an
unfamiliar, you know, situation,
it's much more difficult for me.
Whereas if it's a familiar
situation, I can react, I can almost
predict what's going to be said.
And I think if you're in a country
where the language is spoken and
you're with people a lot, and familiar
people and subjects that, uh, you are
comfortable talking about, uh, and you
get more and more input back at you,
then you are learning and improving
in a situation, and you're learning
primarily because of the input you're
getting back, and also to some extent,
because you're outputting some of the
same words and phrases and concepts.
So that's a, an ideal scenario.
Takes a while to get traction, but
slowly, slowly, slowly by being with
people, friends of yours, you do improve.
But let's look at the other situation.
Let's say that as is the case with
me right now and many language
learners, you're in a place
where the language is not spoken.
So you have to now create opportunities
to speak typically with an online
language partner or with a tutor,
or perhaps you can find people in
your, you know, wherever you live,
that speak the target language.
But that's more difficult to organize.
So inevitably in the second scenario,
you are speaking less often, so
you are getting less, you know,
input material coming back at you.
What can you do?
Well, here again, I think
you have to organize as much
input material as possible.
And as is the case when you are in a,
you know, situation where you can speak
a lot, you wanna try to, you know, input
or find input or surround yourself with
input material that is familiar, that
is comfortable for you, and therefore
depending on your level in the language.
You can go to the mini stories,
particularly if, uh, you have learned
another language, say at LingQ, and so the
mini stories are already familiar to you.
Then you can learn a second language
with these mini stories, but even if
it's your first language that you're
learning, because the mini stories,
the same content basically repeats.
So familiar is good.
The more familiar the content
is, the better you're learning.
And then as you progress in the
language, you'll be, I think you
want to bring in content to listen
to that is of interest to you.
maybe you're familiar with it.
It might be sports, it might be some
other, even, for example, a series
on Netflix where the same people,
the same family meets, you know,
every episode familiar is good.
Also, it now gives you something
to talk to your tutor about.
I have begun with, uh, say Persiabn
doing the mini stories and then having
that tutor ask me those very same
questions that show up in the mini story.
Uh, I've even read with her reading
the mini story because Persian reading,
Persian for me was very difficult.
So you can use the mini stories
as again, familiar content.
Later on, you can work with your tutor.
So that your online conversations can
deal with something that is of interest
to you, which could be sports, which
could be cooking, which could be whatever.
And the tutor might even help you find
content that's in this area of interest.
So again, you're dealing with material
that's familiar to you, that's gonna
make it easier to talk about those
to speak, and it's gonna make it
easier to use that input material
to power up your ability to speak.
So to summarize, I think whether
we can speak our way to fluency
or not depends on where we are.
But in either case, whether we are
in a place where the language is
spoken or whether we are not in a
place where the language is spoken,
we are gonna need a lot of input.
And the more familiar that input is, the
more we're dealing with things that you
like, the better off you're gonna do in
the better you're gonna do in both cases.
And in both cases, you'll be
more comfortable talking about
things that you're familiar.
So just a thought on, uh, this issue of,
of, uh, speaking your way to fluency.
So I hope that was helpful and I
have spoken on this subject before,
and I'll leave you with a couple
of videos that talk about the
relationship between input and output.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.